vsauce kevin here and you have a
dilemma i have two envelopes and you can
only choose
one there's door number one and there's
door
number two uh oh
there's actually three envelopes here
uh great now we no longer have
a dilemma here's why die comes from the
greek
twice and lemma means premise
so a dilemma involves two promises
from which you have to choose adding a
third envelope means that this choice
isn't technically
a dilemma but it does set up a very
famous paradox wait
let's dissect the word paradox like we
just did with dilemma to find out
exactly what
a paradox is okay
pera comes from the greek distinct from
and
dox comes from doxa meaning our
opinion paradox translates literally as
distinct from our opinion so there you
go
now distinct from our opinion
that didn't really help at all i thought
a paradox was like
an unsolvable brain teaser so
how do three envelopes set up
a paradox what is
a paradox
[Music]
in 1961 logician and philosopher willard
van orman kwine
outlined the three categories of
paradoxes
and i have them each hidden inside these
three
envelopes one represents the kind of
paradox that you're most familiar with
those that defy logic like the
impossible waterfall
from this video's intro the other two
are what well
let's crack one of them open and find
out
falsetical this is why achilles can
never catch
a tortoise we'll use this bootleg
rambo to represent achilles and a
ninja turtle pez will be our tortoise
if the tortoise gets a 100 meter head
start
then achilles starts running by the time
he gets to the 100 meter mark
the tortoise will have moved a another
meter
it takes achilles some more time to get
to that 101 meter mark and
in that time the tortoise has moved even
further
achilles will always be catching up to
the place where the tortoise was
as the tortoise inches forward the gap
gets smaller and smaller but the
tortoise is
always slightly ahead
according to greek philosopher zeno of
elia who dreamed up this paradox 2500
years ago
the fastest runner in the world can
never overtake a tortoise in a race
because you can infinitely divide the
distance between them
as the tortoise advances but
that's ridiculous we know it's not true
even with a head start i could outrun a
tortoise and
i'm no achilles so how can this
be a paradox zeno knew achilles could
catch up to the tortoise in real life
but he couldn't prove it mathematically
he thought there would be an
infinite number of new points for the
tortoise to reach
that achilles had to reach because he
didn't know that an infinite series of
numbers could add
up to a finite value no one knew that
for another 2 thousand years
what we now call a convergent series
one-half plus one-fourth plus
one-eighth plus one-sixteenth
plus one-thirty-second goes on forever
but it eventually adds up to one
and at that one is where mathematically
achilles finally reaches the tortoise
we knew that achilles could catch up to
the tortoise but
it took inventing calculus for us to
prove
why which is why this paradox that
confounded great minds for
thousands of years is falsitical
described by quine like this a
falsitical paradox packs a surprise
but it is seen as a false alarm when we
solve
the underlying fallacy okay
that's one paradox envelope down and
two to go and behind number two we have
vertical for this we need
a game show okay i'm gonna replace the
two envelopes we've already
opened with some prizes uh how about
one million dollars will go into one of
them
and the uh glob glow gab collab
will go in the other it's a good enough
prize as any the third envelope still
contains the term for the final type of
paradox which
we'll get to later all right i will uh
shuffle these up
so you don't know which is which now
you've got three
envelopes x y and z
pick the correct one and you win the
grand prize
after you make your selection let's say
envelope
x the game show host reveals what's
inside one of the two
remaining envelopes
it's the glob now there are only
two envelopes left the one that you
chose
and the remaining mystery envelope
he gives you the option to switch your
envelope should you do it
does it even matter i mean at this point
your odds of winning are just
50 50. right
no you should always
switch and here's why the odds of
winning with your first
chosen envelope are one in three so you
have a 33.33
repeating chance of being right and a
66.66 repeating chance of
being wrong when the game show host
revealed the glob
it didn't suddenly improve your odds to
50 50
the proof is in the options after first
choosing an envelope the thing revealed
by the host will never be the money
because well that would ruin the tension
of the game show
so if your initial one out of three pick
wasn't the money and the money is
y then the host will reveal z
if you chose wrong and the money is z
the host reveals
why if you luckily chose the money the
first time then the host can reveal
either z
or why it doesn't matter no matter what
you're still stuck
in that initial 33 chance
that you chose right the very first time
but if you switch regardless of the
prize revealed
you now leap into the 66
zone you've doubled your chances
of getting the money to put it another
way when you're asked if you want to
switch you're actually being given
a dilemma do you want to keep your
single envelope
or do you want both of the other two it
just so happens that you already know
what's inside
one of them but since the one revealed
will never contain the money
the chances that the other unopened one
has the money
are twice as high as the first one that
you chose
the monty hall problem blew up after a
1990 parade magazine columnist advocated
switching doors
in the same scenario from the game show
let's make a deal
when she told readers they should always
switch to improve their odds of winning
nearly a thousand people with phds wrote
in to tell her
that she was wrong she
wasn't wrong they were so the monty hall
paradox
like the potato paradox we recently
covered is an example
of one that is a vertical paradox
one that initially seems wrong but has
proven to be true
quine said a veritical paradox packs a
surprise
but the surprise quickly dissipates
itself as we ponder the proof
okay there are paradoxes that seem
absurd but have a perfectly good
explanation
and ones that seem false and actually
are false because of an underlying
fallacy
even if it takes a major advance in math
to prove it
this last envelope contains the kind
that we think of
when we all think of paradoxes
antinomy the grandfather paradox where
you go back in time to kill your
grandfather when he was a child but that
means your father was never born so you
were never born so how can you go back
in time to kill your grandfather
it's ridiculous metaphysics proposed a
solution to this
but these types of paradoxes are not
true
or false actually they can't be true
and they can't be false as quine put it
they create a
crisis in thought i
am
lying if i'm lying when i say that
then i must actually be telling the
truth but
how can i be telling the truth if i'm
lying
the liar's paradox is an example of
antinomy
which literally means against laws and
highlights a serious
logical incompatibility quan
said
klein said that this tape thing was a
good idea in theory but
uh in practice not so much
quine said an antinomy packs a surprise
that can be accommodated
by nothing less than a repudiation of
part
of our conceptual heritage
here's the thing antinomies are
paradoxes to us
all falsitical and theoretical paradoxes
are only paradoxes to those who don't
know the solution
but they still have value every time we
resolve a scenario that runs counter to
hour or someone else's initial
expectations
every time we learn the how and the why
and share that information we're
refining
and clarifying knowledge which makes
all three types of paradoxes excellent
tools
for reasoning whether or not something
is paradoxical to an individual
depends on the accuracy of their
expectations
today modern mathematics has given us
the ability to show
that zeno's paradoxes are falsitical
but they were pure antinomy unresolved
to
everyone for millennia coin himself said
one man's antinomy is another man's
falsitical paradox
give or take a couple of thousand years
who knows which antinomies of today will
be
solved in the future right now we
struggle with the paradox
of the faint young sun our current
knowledge of stars
says that billions of years ago our sun
wasn't hot enough to keep the earth from
being a ball of ice
but our geological evidence shows an
ancient earth with
liquid oceans and budding life when
everything should have been frozen
how could the earth have liquid water
without a
sun hot enough to melt ice
it's antinomy until we fully
comprehend the situation maybe our
current understanding of the sun
isn't perfect or maybe our knowledge of
early earth
is missing some pieces a paradox is a
problem where the solution
is or is made to seem impossible
sometimes they're purposefully designed
for fun because our minds like puzzles
sometimes we just stumble on a gap
between what we know
and how we talk about what we know and
what is
actually true when we solve an
impossible antinomy
it becomes falsitical or veritical
someone who knows the answer can see
what the problem was
all along we tricked ourselves by
knowing too little or by asking the
wrong
question in one way or another all
paradoxes come
from people by challenging us to find
the flaw or
fill the gap in our knowledge paradoxes
help us define
and push our intellectual boundaries
there's always more for us to know
whether we
know it or not and as always
thanks for watching